my name is Anisha petku I'm the program
manager for this year's Berlin science
week and I actually come from the
cultural sector I studied cultural
sciences and cultural project management
but then I found my way to Berlin
science week
I think knowledge should be accessible
for everyone and by that I really mean
everyone I think it's important that we
make it
transparent and that I feel like we have
a responsibility to make sure that
everybody has access and that everybody
can be a part of the conversation and
that's exactly what we're doing at
Berlin science week
knowledge what's the knowledge that we
use what's knowledge that we're not
seeing as important at the moment what
is something that we need to know and we
don't know and who are we giving the
opportunity to speak at the moment